vegas now spring has sprung if you
haven't felt that and entertaining
expert paul zahn
is back with his tips on the season's
must-haves hey paul
how are you first let's get into some
spring cleaning we are going to be
better on
the environment and better on our
wallets with some sun harvest products
from smart and final now all of these
products are natural inorganic products
and the containers are made from like
biodegradable materials so again
better for the environment they're
inexpensive and
smart and final really has everything
you need to win this spring
including these products and they also
have compostable
knives and forks for that salmon summer
in spring barbecue and smart and
final.com
you can order stuff and they deliver it
don't we love that we love that
definitely since you know the panda we
enjoy getting everything delivered
hello but also during this time we can
enjoy
some cocktails right absolutely
absolutely i love to come up with this
spring cocktail in a spring wine so
first let's start with the cocktail
we are working with some barren yeager
honey and bourbon it's a combination of
honey from germany and bourbon from
the united states and it's perfect on
the rocks it's gluten-free
and it makes some really wonderful
cocktails and then we also have some 135
east gin so this is a japanese gin that
has some
standard botanicals from like a dry
english gin
and then we need a good wine oh yes
we have some kenwood vineyards which is
a sonoma based
vineyard that really pulls from the wild
of sonoma when making their wines and
they take a small lot approach
it's accessible it is high quality and
when you're out there grilling
pick up a bottle of this i'm gonna do a
spring charcuterie board with the
kenwood vineyards
six ridges you know sauvignon blanc
so much with these cocktails and drinks
and everything for spring right
yes you are speaking my language with
the charcuterie board and of course
during our small gatherings
during this time we want to have some
party games
what do you got for us there absolutely
absolutely we need to have a fun
party game so what i have for you guys
today is fun fact
so this is a new multiplayer game
app that lets you really shine with your
personality
let me explain how it works so using
hundreds of provocative prompts
you know you download the app and then
players fill in a blank
with something that really shows their
personality then the group
tries to figure out who answered what
question if you guess who answered the
right question right
you win some points now this app is free
available on the
apple store and they have a dozen
different types of decks so they have
adults only type of games they have
family friendly games they have ones you
can do for work
my favorite is hidden talents so fun
facts has been
great games and stuff like that don't
you think
i love all of your ideas all the time
paul thank you so much where can we find
more information really quick
paulzan.com okay we will head there
thank you so much ken dawson over to you